brought to you by PlayStation Store
access to the ultimate and games and
entertainment almost two-and-a-half
years after the first game hotline Miami
2 is that today on the PC and a variety
of different Sony PlayStation consoles I
reviewed it for gamespot.com
gave it a 9 out of 10 that games pretty
rad and Chris I saw you were playing it
just before we came on I was and right
from the get-go I mean it's you know the
hotline Miami has not issued the serious
identity by any stretch in fact they've
kind of doubled like leaned into it even
more and so I was like I'm playing I'm
playing and I'm remembering to listen to
the soundtrack and remembering to sort
of get into the groove of it and it
draws you right in and it's you know
it's same same old kind of thing what
would you say Danny are like the salient
differences though I mean is it just
more awesome hotline Miami or do they
kind of complexify and other made up
words it the two the two things that I
found different were in this one there
is there's a lot more variety in terms
of the levels and what's in them and
then a lot less variety in terms of your
ability to like choose who you want to
be going into them so the first game was
all about like unlocking those masks and
then you know thinking okay this looks
like a level that if I played like Tony
the Tiger who is like the the silent
take down and mask dude that you know
that might be for one or maybe this
levels got a lot of dogs in it so I for
the dog masks the dogs won't attack me
anymore so you kind of played it that
way in this one ultimately you don't
actually have that much agency in terms
of choosing masks there's a couple
there's like this main troop of four
five actually and individuals who you
can pick from at any stage or in the in
their levels but then there's levels
where you're just playing as this like
butcher on this film set and this
detective and this journalist and they
have their own thing going on like the
detective basically always use the lead
gun so you just kind of have to get over
that and the journalist is trying to
silently take people down so if you pick
up a gun with the journalist he just
dumps the ammunition out of the gun and
picks up a baseball bat instead so
you're like forced to play the levels in
a totally different way and then inside
of the levels there's a lot more variety
in terms of like enemy types and angles
and wanna now it's interesting because
you obviously
loved that you you actually rather
enjoyed the the way that it pushed you
through different playstyles in that way
is interesting though because reading
reading PC gamers read Idol was was very
different they they I mean they they
touched on that point but they clearly
think that it takes away the specialness
of hotline Miami what are some of the
other things that you think just really
keep this game special and you know the
soundtrack obviously sounds like one of
its yeah it's one of these things where
I feel like you're free not like I loved
I grew up in electronic music back home
and Ireland but and I love that stuff
and that's what I listen to normally
anyway and the soundtrack and this is
not only it's as good as the last game
but there's a bit 50 tracks I think and
all oh wow I am on it so it's a lot more
varied I wonder if this is the type of
game that you could not play or enjoy as
much if you didn't like really enjoy the
time you like or just the entire
aesthetic and style that it's producing
because it's such a like it so evocative
of like like my teenage life or like or
just like the era I was like born so it
kind of grew up in that there's so many
like touch stones in it that remind me
of in the same way when you play like a
classic platformer and it like tickles
that you know just an extra little
something in the way it's like presented
and I just everything about this game
style in terms of how it looks how it
sounds I absolutely adore well it seems
like when you're talking about the masks
and how they've basically I mean it
restricted your ability to choose the
there's a reason for that restriction
like it serves a narrative purpose it
serves a framing for this kind of game
this kind of tactics in this kind of
area kind of thing it seems like it it's
a lot more directed of an experience and
with that comes narrative I mean but my
sort of experience early on is like this
is just a bunch of vignettes that I like
yeah I'm having trouble stitching
together and I don't think that ever
changes that one of the biggest
criticisms I had was that the story
stuff especially in the first third is
just so it's late on so thick it's kind
of gobbledygook you kind of don't it's
basically it's it's like Pope you know
this is pulp this is just kind of
nonsensical like on repeated
playthroughs of the first game are it
made a lot more sense when I played this
a second
through it made a lot more sense as well
and you kind of appreciate it that way
but what I enjoyed about the lack of
selection in terms of like here is where
you got to choose between a couple of
mosques yeah but that's that's pretty
rare but what I enjoyed about it was the
problem with the first game was it's a
really difficult game
and shooting was the hardest part and
they had a lock-on button which made the
mess and keyboard controls a little bit
easier which basically meant like you
could queue up a shot and then when you
rounded the corner you'd be already
facing that person okay and the thing
about it was you never really got good
at like free shooting in hotline mommy
in this one because there are characters
who only shoot and only shoot loud you
have to learn it so you're forced to get
better at shooting and so I can see like
when I read the PC game or review I
found it fascinating that the thing that
I appreciate about it so much was what
that reviewer didn't like and not to
sound like I think I'm better at this
game than that reviewer but like I was
pretty good at the first game and when I
played this one I remember thinking if I
was finding this frustrating this would
did I be losing my mind right if I was
repeating a level where like I wasn't
the music wasn't carrying me through it
which sometimes it was or I wasn't
getting good at you know picking off
people from far away or outside of the
screens boundary which happens a lot
more in this one I probably frustrated
the thing that I loved the most probably
was the the swan mask duo which is a one
character who rides as a shot as a
chainsaw upfront and then like always in
tandem behind him is another character
with a pistol so they back-to-back is
that no that one over the shoulder the
shoulder would be done Oh
Oh neat but you can basically you're
left clicking for the chainsaw and then
right clicking for the pistol ouch and
the first time your chainsawing someone
and somebody walks in the room over
there and you just go bang with the
other guy and the headshot it's like
well and you never I never would have
done that in the first game because I
just would have picked one of the easy
melee characters or yeah done that thing
in the first hotline where you basically
just like fire around made everyone run
into a room and took them out one by one
by one well it certainly seems I mean
it's not an easy game never say right
and so you're talking about like what
what fuels you pass the repetition you
know sometimes it's the music sometimes
it's the fact that you're actually
getting put into these specifically
different scenarios with specific
different masks so they encourage that
kind of different
tactics but the the act on a single
level of figuring out your path through
it figuring out your tactics trying out
different things like running into walls
and deciding if that wall is I'm just
not executing properly or I need to be
doing something entirely different like
I did the risk that games like this
always run is where does the user like
hit a wall and give up versus where do
they hit the wall and say I'm gonna bust
right through that wall so like how does
where did you how was that for you
reviewing it like that hotline Miami did
they come in how do they handle it I
think they fixed a lot of it there were
like three or four different instances
some of which I can recall actually
still to this day in the first game that
were just so frustratingly impossible or
or you but you had to game the game to
get past them and like just you know
[ __ ] your way around the level never
in the first game you kind of go out of
your limb sometime and just run and gone
and go crazy and maybe try it every once
in a while but ultimately you'd sit back
and be conservative and complete the
level just that way in this one I had
more success sometimes just running in
and blasting stuff and being twitchy and
just trying to take people out like
screaming in your head the whole time
just like and then and then you stopped
after you've like just you know used it
all of your ammo and an Uzi and baseball
bat at someone you picked up another gun
and then you stop and realize oh there's
only like two dudes left in this level
yeah I'm actually dumbest okay yeah yeah
everything's covered in blood was in the
first game you never really did then the
first game it's something about you know
you can take bullets this time around
you know if they graze you mm-hmm I
think the enemies
I wasn't sure is playing again last
night I was thinking I think the enemies
might actually be a less accurate in
this one than they were in the first as
well but whatever is going on you're
definitely encouraged to just run and
gone a lot more and when you've
completed level doing that like I never
before in this game there was a bit of
footage earlier of like a boat level I
would try I try to complete it in one go
without dying which I would never even
consider in the first dollar army you
were just like restart below yeah I was
like I just want to get to the next
other because this one's so difficult
right but what I was actually doing was
going no I'll go back to the menu and I
want to and I managed to get through the
first three areas in the 430 so he's
getting me so and then I go back and
have another go now a lot of people with
the first game a lot of people said that
you know because it's very violent yeah
I mean both games are violent but this
this sounds extraordinarily violent I
don't know and I'm kind of curious about
because a lot of people said well the
first game actually was saying something
about violence um you know the idea the
idea side of whether a violent game has
it can actually have something
meaningful to say about violence do you
feel like the second game tries to do
something similar did you get the same
feeling like going back through the
level after everybody was dead and
seeing all that blood and thinking
you're just a terrible human being
well do you remember in the first game
when you you play and it was a pumping
sand track and then when you killed the
last person they were just kind of and
in silent it was silent and you had to
walk your way out yeah does that happen
now it's the same but because you've
already done us in that previous game it
just doesn't really feel as a lack of
effort what's its power and I do think
it's it's probably trying to say
something like it wouldn't go out of its
way to have say a passive journalist who
is always like dumping rands but who
actually if you do certain things if you
knock somebody on the ground and then
battered their heads in he'll actually
matter their heads in the screen will
get a bit crazy while he's doing it so
and also there's a there's a scene which
you can decide not to have in your
playthrough white at the off that is a
basically a scene of sexual violence
which happens in the first five minutes
of the game which is kind of in it's so
short but it's in there so now it has
it's in there for a reason like I never
really and the first thing I did when
you play the game is say yes or no I
want I want these to be left out or I
want them do left and I did both and
it's basically four seconds of pixel
animation that happens it doesn't happen
but ultimately like it's hard to draw
the thing with the first game was the
story was kind of that same gobbledygook
like put jumping back and forth like
intentionally hobb the skating certain
elements I was kind of trying to set a
mood more generally on the first
playthrough yeah but that first game is
about three hours long whereas this one
feels like it's at least like two two
and a half times longer so you can't
pull that trick of being that vague over
that period of time mhm and still have
like a core message so no like on my
second playthrough I didn't really feel
like I was doing that so okay certainly
uh yeah it's kind of one of those games
like you feel like it would be great if
it just did that thing it'll be like
even better but ultimately I don't think
that's why I'm you
I'm playing hotline man me too but yeah
it's a it's out today on PC PlayStation
4 PlayStation 3 air Vita as well and
it'll probably end up coming to Xbox
consoles I imagined judging from my
Sony's timed exclusive my exclusive
thing which doesn't seem as aggressive
as Microsoft